[Music]
so I have to say you've definitely had
some memorable moments in the season and
folks will find your memorable moments
this season but one through three what's
been your favorite moment of the
franchise we both said I think it's
something that we can't necessarily say
about the current season yeah that's
we're kind of talking about earlier
that's obvious we get we got some
episode so folks can be on the lookout
for it it's like seven and eight yeah
Ali this finale that's like your
favorite see the franchise I think I
think so yeah okay I've never seem to do
okay I don't know if it was I don't know
if like out of all the things that
everyone has done it would be the one
that I would say like there are so many
scenes that I love yeah well like other
characters storylines and so that was my
favorite one to do for sure yeah what
was your favorite one of somebody else's
that you got to watch from the season or
from any season eight well let's go the
first two so that way you don't give any
spoilers
I love the prom so much that's that was
incorrect that's that was beautiful and
it was such a like yeah such a rewarding
moment I really just like the opening
scene of the boys playing Dungeons &
Dragons I thought it's like maybe the
quickest the quickest way into like a
show ever
I don't know it's like you instantly oh
I totally understand what these
characters they're dynamic together and
it just immediately kind of sets that
yeah let's talk about how your
characters changed over the first three
seasons like his evolution it's been
pretty great sure yeah cuz it goes from
you know kind of being like a selfish
narcissist kind of [ __ ] character to
slowly growing up and discovering what
it means to put other people before
yourself and I think that this season
kind of picks up where that is left off
and kind of more questions about you
know just your life what do you want to
do what do you want to be and how do you
kind of get there to start to kind of
fit
and then also for us-- it's been like
season 1 you've seen these kids get like
complete you know grown-ups almost now
yes so what's upsetting what's it like
watching them basically grow up in front
of you with the 5 just like they're like
cousins or something I think they're my
little cousins that I get to see you
like oh we're gonna hang out and you
know we get to hang out again every once
in a while but they're great they're
just like really solid people especially
under the circumstance of having so many
people just interested in them who they
are yeah I just love the kids that are
made they're really impressive um are
they asking you guys for any advice like
hey words of wisdom no hell no no they
know way more no way more um both of you
guys have been acting for a while did
you guys have like first summer jobs did
you have like your McDonald's gig I
worked in a bookstore I uh was your
first time ago I was a pizza delivery
guy I for I was like a busboy for a long
time a lot of restaurant jobs did you
fire anything babysitting didn't get
fired no yeah I did actually babysit my
sister's occasionally that's nice legs
preparation yeah it's like building up
right and then what's your favorite
fourth of July activity what do you like
to do in 4th I like being with my family
going to Cape Cod that's kind of a
tradition in our family so I like doing
that fireworks afternoon Billy take the
new suit mrs. really thank you
you came in in season two and gave me a
moment that I sort of loved but hated
because you were so mean like when you
got there but when you like major
insurance I was like that's a great like
TV moment it's one of my face I was very
lucky that I had that entrance well
what's one of your favorite moments from
the franchise I don't know it's so hard
to pick it apart I mean it's so beloved
I think in many ways but I think for me
obviously the opening credits were a big
thing the first time the night that it
came out I watched the whole season and
I remember that and you know that the
letters coming up in that bold neon read
and just feeling like this is something
unique I think in a lot of ways and I
think that's reflective of the actual
show so you only have season two to go
by but what's different about your
character between last year and this
year no spoilers
totally no spoilers I think what's
different is that we see a much darker
side of Billy that doesn't have this
humanized quality that we saw in season
two with the scene with his dad those
sort of things until the end we have
such a fantastic payoff at the end of
season three but I got to delve so deep
into making unusual choices that I think
puts the audience on edge which was
really exciting and I was really lucky
my story arc is so fleshed out this
season working with the kids because it
was like a year between season 2 and
season 3 but off the law yeah what's it
like watching these kids like I think
Caleb started to get a little bit of
like bum fluff going on around under his
nose and I love it I mean we love like
sort of heckling I would um but no I
just
I think the maturity and and the ability
under living in the public eye the
complete loss of their anonymity I think
the ability to still remain humble and
work hard is I have a lot of admiration
for that because at 13 14 and 15 and 16
like you wouldn't have had me doing that
so I think that's really I respect that
yeah 13 14 15 16 here is when people get
their first summer job well yes your
first summer job I worked in a butch up
I scraped like the frozen blood off the
floor then I worked at McDonald's
and I got fired and then I was a dish
big in a barista for five years so I had
an interesting I bring I never worked in
like
retail which I was a bit different to
the butcher looking back on it what you
get fired for I can't remember it was
something super silly like I was working
with my Knights and we were mucking
around and something homeless well here
we have the 4th of July as like our
summer holiday and everyone like
barbecues in those fireworks so I don't
know what the Australia Australia is
yeah but what is your favorite activity
on that day well in Australia we get
super wasted and we listen to this thing
called Triple J's hottest 100 which is
where over the course of the day up
until the fireworks in the evening they
count down the hottest 100 songs that
the country has voted over the last year
and they're not just pop songs they're
super alternative like the station is
like the alternative station so
everything and you can't down and you
drink and you drink and you drink and
I'm not a big drinker so you'll probably
get me in 3 p.m. but but it the
fireworks and the number one happens at
like 10:00 p.m. and that's kind of our
big day yeah I don't want to like go to
Australia participate in this you look
we want to come here and participate in
the 4th of July so I get to do it
fictitiously in the show and I get to do
it in real life in a couple of days so
it'll be good together
hi guys I'm so excited I'm ready to see
the season and I will say that you guys
gave me one of my favorite but also
least favorite moments is when you
friendzone Tim in season 1 with that
gift I'm not gonna lie I was so upset
but what was your favorite moment from
the franchise Oh hmm just that first
season yeah I was the back so from this
sort of yeah there's the ILA I love like
the whole on this but like the whole end
and I'm kind of fighting the Danakil in
the trees no I really night tonight I it
was cold it was really cold that morning
with our morning we shot the guns just
thank you.thank scenes that don't seem
much but just in your mind you're like
oh that was a good day it was a fun day
yeah that means you guys are having too
much oh my favorite moment I think is
we're in the woods
actually yeah stuff in the woods is
really cool especially night yeah yeah
yeah so how do you think your character
I mean no spoilers has changed I mean
this is not three seasons and the kids
are getting older you guys have had a
whole transformation very happy about
that by the way yeah I think they've
just matured no all characters they've
you know going through what they've been
through together in the first two
seasons and trying to get on with some
normal normality and trying to push
through Assad but there this season they
did you know they've got so much job
starting into young adults
just must be interesting for you guys to
cuz you're literally watching them go
from like children's to like you know
young adult okay so how has it been
working with them through that
transitions that's such good kids and
every year they come back and you know
we have those choice blown up so I have
their careers but they're you know
they're really good it just kind of it's
still good you know they're still young
and like it still gets really silly when
everybody's in the same scene together
and so this is all fourth of July so
what is your favorite I know you're
British maybe a fourth of July holiday
too maybe what's your favorite BBQ
holiday or summer activity but here at
the 4th you know people do fireworks to
do all kind stuff so do you have them
well we don't you know new hundred
fourth of July I think I like Christmas
it's my favorite time yeah okay any
fourth of July sort of things that you
like yeah I mean you know I think it's
about just being around you know people
you want to be around having a cookout
maybe some fireworks we got a good
fourth of July this year yeah we had a
pool a pool oh god he's just like you
know like hang just like a good hang day
right I like that we did a talent show
ah I want to be in it alright thank you
guys
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]